morning everybody uh my name is Michael
Volos and you know today I'm going to be
talking about border flow you know that
was just a great presentation um by
silus earlier and you know it it's just
fascinating there's so many different
ways to approach the market and what
I'll be talking about is the way I
approach the market you know people
trade very short-term medium-term
long-term orderflow is on the very
shortterm spectrum of trading so in this
training I'm going to show you how to
identify aggressive Traders trade in
sync with the market and I'll talk about
a low-risk orderflow trade setup right
we
all like to have uh trades but we also
want to have lowrisk trade setups and
I'm going to be talking about uh that a
little bit later now if you stay till
the end I'm going to show you how to get
a copy of the book that I wrote on
orderflow it's called trading order flow
and it's going to teach you how to
determine what the institutions are
doing it's going to talk about how not
all prices are the same how to limit
your risk on a trade how to determine
price rejection how to understand value
in the market and much more so if you
stick around till the end you be able to
get a free copy of this it'll be a
digital download it's not going to be
the actual hard
copy now why orderflow well to me
orderflow is the market right it's not
some indicator or Fibonacci or pivot
Points right orderflow
is the trading that's occurring in the
market
as um you know as people are buying and
selling in in the two-way auction and
only orderflow gets you as close to the
market as possible now people are going
to say what what what does that mean get
me as close to the market as possible
well you now everything is screen traded
okay and you know in the old days there
used to be the the trading floor where
you know people would pay a lot of money
to be members on the trading floor to
see who's buying and who's selling you
know if there's a lot of volume coming
into the market or not as opposed to
just looking at you know ticks on the
screen now what orderflow does is it
allows you to see that volume in the
market and once you understand order
flow you're going to understand the
market right this is all the charts I'm
showing you is from yesterday right the
uh December 16th you I like to keep it
current you know to show you that this
what I talk about happens every day in
the market so this was the e- minis I'm
going to show you how to see what other
Traders don't see which lead to the big
moves in the market you know snps you
know all these markets nowadays a lot of
volatility you get big moves intraday
which is is is great you know this is
Japanese Yen right by using the order
flow you're going to see and understand
what's happening in the market more
clearly this is wheat right a nice move
from the low of the day straight up and
I'm going to show you how to easily read
an orderflow footprint chart this is an
orderflow footprint chart as opposed to
a normal bar chart and you're going to
see there's a lot of of information if
you know what to look for you I'm not
saying you have to analyze every tick
you know that's what some people will
have you believe that order flow is
about is about analyzing every single
tick that goes through and trying to you
know sort of put it in pieces of the
overall trading
puzzle so before I get started I want to
talk about who I am and why you should
listen to me about orderflow so this is
the first time you're one of my
presentations my name is Michael Volos
I've got over 25 years of professional
trading experience I started on the CME
floor in the early 90s with Dean Whitter
Reynolds I literally started at the
bottom I said I want to be in in the
finance industry I started as a runner
on the CME floor that's the the lowest
you can start okay and eventually you
know I I worked my way up from there um
after I left the CME trading floor with
with Dean Whitter I went to the
electronic trading desk which is um when
Globex when the electronic Market
started becoming popular back in the
early 90s and I spent a few years there
then I left um Dean Witter I joined the
global macro trading desk at EDF manual
it's a big English Trading Company I
spent a couple years there then I joined
Comer bank I became the licensed urex
Trader in Chicago um you know the only
one in Commerce Bank in Chicago that was
able to trade buns bobbles shats Dax you
know all the German products against the
US products after that I joined Cargill
the big American commodity trading firm
you know it's I think now it's the
second largest um private firm in
America Coke Industries I think just
became first but you know it accounts
for about 30% of grain exports and about
25% of meat exports but they trade
everything anything around the world
that that's tradeable Cargill is got
their fingers in it after Carill Cargill
sent me out to Singapore actually to set
up a trading desk for them in Singapore
when the trading floor on simex closed
down and so after um a few years at
Cargill I left and I joined JP Morgan
vice president of Futures Trading sat on
the trading desk you know I wasn't
sitting in a corner office looking at
charts I was on the trading that's
banging out trades all day long from
6:00 in the morning when Globex reopened
in the US until about uh 5 o'clock in
the evening Singapore time and in 2013 I
left JP Morgan after my daughter was
born to spend more time with my family I
I just needed to get away from the
corporate Rat Race and trade for myself
I started writing my book and in 2015 I
started order flows okay but this
presentation is not about me right it's
about showing you how you can improve
your trading by understanding what's
happening in the market use order flows
um you know this is one of my users you
know who writes to me uh I can clearly
see now what's happening in the market
for example who's in control of the
market on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well right I I want
you to understand what's happening in
the market now you know disclaimer the
charts and tools that use in this
training are generated for my orderflow
software right I said in 2015 I started
a a software company called orderflows
and what I'm going be talking about
today can easily be applied with um
other orderflow footprint software if
you know what to look for I find mine
you know I created my software to help
my own trading that's how order flows
started right I I was using another
company's orderflow tool but it wasn't
good enough it was just a very basic
thing and I I said you know what
computers should be able to do a lot
more than just plot data on there you
know I wanted to help me do the analysis
so I could look at more markets and sort
of You Know cover more things so I'm
going to show you how to easily and
quickly apply orderflow analysis to your
trading so you make better trades right
lowrisk trades now before I begin you
know I just want you to understand you
know trading is risky right you should
only um trade with capital you can
afford to lose and make sure you got
sufficient capital that's that's
separate from your living expenses so
what I want to talk about today is you
know aggressive Traders right people say
yeah what what's aggressive Traders
well being able to identify aggressive
Traders is the easiest way to make sense
of the order flow right order flow is
about identifying the immediate trends
of prices right where the next um four
or five ticks are going to be and if if
this move is going to continue right an
orderflow Trader makes decisions from
each succeeding trade
in the market you know every you know
think of the market as a kaleidoscope
you know those things you look into and
you twist it um you know order flow
Traders are always gauging the supply
and demand and the forces behind it but
what really causes a market to move it's
the aggressive
Traders but what exactly is an
aggressive Trader right this is a
picture of trading Dome okay and you see
there's bids and there's offers right
there's the best bid the best offer
right markets trade in a two-way auction
a lot of Traders don't think in terms of
the two-way auctions you just think of
well the price you know the market
traded uh
3691 um but you can see here right
it's 91 bid at 89 and 3/4 okay so it's
kind of a wide bid offer but because I
left out 3690 um but you can see people
that are working on the bid and below
are what's considered passive buyers
right you can see the 101 the 164 the
296 the 26 for the 289 all these people
are what's considered a passive buyer
they're waiting for the market to trade
down before they buy whereas passive
sellers are those on the offer and above
you know they're happy to sell at 3691
if the market comes to them they're
happy to sell at 91 and a quarter if the
market comes to them they are no
rush to trade right they're they're
considered passive sellers so you have
an order book right the order book is
full of passive buyers and and passive
sellers but the aggressive Traders are
the ones who cause the market to move
you know there's a saying you know in
the old days us be have to call your
broker why did the market go up and you
would say well there was more buyers
than than sellers okay well that that
that's really misinformation
disingenuous information because what's
actually happening on a move up is there
more aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers right you have passive buyers
here but there's more people buying the
offer for you know buying everything out
at this level 3691 clear it out they buy
everything at 3691 and a quarter right
so there's there's not more buyers than
sellers what you have is more aggressive
buyers than passive sellers going on
that that's what's causing the market to
move up because they're they're clearing
out all the bid sorry all the offers in
the market on the way up just as on a
move down there's more aggressive
selling than buyers so
markets don't move because a Traders
working bids and offer okay and you know
a lot of people that that trade on a
dome you know they they actually you
know they they sit here they like to
look at a dome you know just like this
right stare at your screen and see it
flashing back and forth big numbers
coming in and you know they may see a
big offer or big bid come in and and
they try to jump in front of it you know
that that's one of the deadliest things
to do actually is is sometimes jump in
front of a big order in the sense that
it's just sitting in the book
okay because you know even though
there's there's laws against spoofing
you know it sort of does still happen in
a way you know people think that oh my
gosh you know there's a big bid at
3689 I'm going to buy you know the 89
and a quarters I'm I'm going to just
jump in front because there's a big
buyer they must want to get it but
speaking as an Institutional Trader
right I I I did that for you know over
20 years is as a big Trader when you see
big size in the market Market that's
your opportunity you know if you know if
we wanted to sell and and someone shows
3689 bid for 800 and I got a th000 to
sell even though the market is trading
89 and 3/4 uh bid I just hit it all down
to 89 because I know that I'm such a big
Trader I've got a lot of you know Supply
to sell if I see a big bid there I'm
just going to hit it because I have so
much to sell that eventually the market
my selling is going to move the market
down so if somebody puts a big bid in
there I'm just going to whack it okay so
you that that's not what a lot of retail
Traders think they actually think the
opposite they think well there's a big
buyer you know couple ticks below the
market the market must be going up um
that's not what moves markets right it's
the actual trades that move the markets
so for a trade to
happen the aggressive buyer has to cross
the bid offer and lift the offer right
aggressive aggressive buyers buy from
the passive sellers aggressive sellers
on the other hand they cross the bid
offer and sell into the bid they sell to
the passive buyers all right so you know
again think of the two-way auction there
there's a bid and there's an offer in
the
market so trying to watch order flow on
a dome is hard you know it really it
moves so fast and if you look away to to
sip of water or pick up your phone or
something you could miss something
important in the market but an orderflow
chart right a footprint
chart is really you know what I consider
the the only chart you need to look at
because it has a lot of the information
and what's beautiful about an orderflow
chart a footprint chart is you know like
the previous speaker sylus right you can
actually put those tools on a footprint
chart and you can find
better trading opportunities because
you're going to see what's happening in
the market right with the aggressive
Traders okay so you can see you know
there's a lot of numbers here people get
scared they look at a footprint chart
and think oh my gosh so much numbers I
don't know what to make of this but when
I first walked on the trading floor at
the CME I thought it was complete chaos
but after you know a day or two after it
was explained to me what to look for
what I was looking at I understood it
right and and a footprint chart is the
same way right see the volume traded on
the bid the volume traded on the offer
at a price at a two-way auction um you
can see where markets are strong markets
are weaker there's just so much
information on there you can see where
the aggressive buyers are present you
can see where aggressive sellers are
present so aggressive Traders you know
how by now hopefully you can understand
what an aggressive Trader is right it's
someone that wants to get filled
basically right the passive buyer or
passive seller is just someone happy to
sit on the bid or the offer wait for the
market to come to them but an aggressive
Trader says you know what I want to I
want to get filled I I need to get out
of this position just sell it at the
market that's an aggressive Trader okay
and aggressive Traders cause imbalances
in the market and can be seen in the
orderflow footprint chart now aggressive
trading can also be seen in the
orderflow Delta number so Delta and in
balances are two of the most important
pieces of Market generated information
from the order flow now just really
quick Delta orderflow Delta don't be
confusing it with options Delta which is
something completely different in
orderflow Delta is the net difference
between aggressive buyers in a bar and
aggressive sellers in a bar so generally
if a bar has negative Delta it's telling
you aggressive sellers were in control
of a bar and conversely if generally if
a bar has positive Delta aggressive
buyers were in control of the bar now
sometimes it may deviate a little bit
but but that's that's a whole another
presentation for another time now
imbalances orderflow imbalances are the
result of aggressive trading in the
two-way auction now you can determine
what you consider an imbalance okay I
mean the industry standard is 4: one
some people use 3: one some people use
5: one some people use 10 to1 you know
9.87 to1 um it it's up to you they said
the industry standard is is 4:1 3:1 is
also very nice so when aggressive buyers
outnumber aggressive sellers by a
certain percentage it's considered a
buying bet imbalance and it's going to
be a blue number in the footprint it's
going to appear there the volume will
appear blue as you can see um you know
in this on these green bars here you
have buying IM balances when aggressive
sellers outnumber aggressive buyers by a
certain percentage it's considered a
selling imbalance right it's in the
two-way auction right so you can see 123
traded on the bid versus six on the
offer that's more than you know 4 to1
that's considered an imbalance I have
this chart set to 3:1 um you know 273
against 70 is more than 3:1 um 258
against 34 is also an imbalance right so
you can see the red numbers generally
were going to appear on um down red
candles and generally buying and
balances are going to appear on green
candles and people say well well if you
got buying IM balances in green bars and
selling IM balances red bars I don't
need orderflow
well when you get to lows of the day
right you're always going to want to be
looking for signs in the market that the
the move down is over right I'm not
trying to pick a low I'm letting the
market tell me the low has been made or
the high has been made I'm going to be
looking for um aggressive selling coming
into the market okay now when aggressive
Traders cause Market imbalances and
there are multiple imbalances in bar
that tells you a market is out of
balance so you know like I said you know
often bars have buying and selling
imbalances but when you see bars that
have one two three four imbalances one
two three imbalances especially when a
bar has only one two 3 four five six
seven price levels but literally half
the bar is buying imbalances what do you
think that means right it means that
aggressive sellers have finally stepped
into the market and you would expect the
market to Rally just as if you had a red
bar a down candle with a lot of selling
imbalances it's telling you the
aggressive selling is really strong and
the market probably has more capacity to
move down right and when a market is out
of balance that's often when vertical
moves start because one side is in
control of the market but what I'm be
focusing on today is imbalances I'm not
going to talk about Delta today I'm be
talking about imbalances so what do you
see in these bars here you have three
green bars off this low here off the
swing low you got a a bar with two
imbalances two buying imbalances a bar
with 1 two 3 four buying imbalances
another bar with one two three buying
imbalances so the market has been
selling off this goes sideways at this
point you should be asking is is there
more potential for this Market to go
lower or is buying come in finally come
in and it looks like we're going to
start a trend up right A reversal from
this move down that's where the order
flow is going to help
you you know on a Candlestick chart this
is the same chart right here what you're
seeing on this orderflow chart is this
chart right this normal Candlestick
chart you just see the Open high low
close right and people will say well
yeah I I you know we close lower than
when we open obviously sellers are in
control okay you know they'll say well
you know down here you got these pin
bars well here you had a pin bar right
you had the same type of bar
right the um hammer formation right
Market traded down and then buying came
in moved it back up but then you just
traded lower traded lower okay maybe you
took this trade you got stopped out but
why should you take this trade if
there's nothing in the order flow to
tell you to be getting long just as here
you know if you're buying buying the
next bar your stop is right below the
low you just got ticked out right so you
you had two losing trades but if you
just wait for the order flow to tell you
you know aggressive buying is coming in
it came in on these three green bars you
know that was that was your sign and
people say well you had a lot of red
bars down and you got some green you
know you just buy it well you had green
bars earlier and you still went down so
you know it's you know trading is a
little is not
complicated once you understand who's in
control if there's anybody in control
sometimes you know the market there's no
one side in control of the market it's
just doing what it's supposed to do it's
facilitating trade people are
trading but with orderflow you can see
without a doubt right when the market is
exhibiting imbalances right because
you're analyzing what is being traded in
the market right you can see the markets
come down you know you got the last
couple sell of balances right here then
it's all buying and balances you know
two four another three you know so you
got you know 10 buying imbalances almost
literally at almost at every price level
on the way back up
right so at this point you should you
know when we hit this 3682 yesterday
that attracted buyers that you know
people thought the market was cheap and
came in with a Vengeance and said hey
you know what this is a very good buying
opportunity and they came in and started
buying right but that's e minis what
about other markets here's crude oil
yesterday right knowing areas of
imbalance is is going to help you again
you know you had this nice sell off down
to 472 25 you know just sort of goes
sideways in here Market went up and it
pulled back literally right to this
level why because in here where this
arrow is pointing is there's buying
inbalances you can't see it on a normal
Candlestick chart the information is
just not available to you so this is
that area in that box right here right
here right the bar you know we got four
buying
imbalances okay and even in some of
these other bars preceding it you've got
a couple green candles with two buy and
balances another two buying imbalances
so you know buyers are being attracted
right we just had a sell off from 4770
down to 4730 you know nice 40 Cent move
okay and then the market is sort of
going
sideways but buyers are stepping into
the market you could see the nice um
aggressive buying even in these red bars
you've got aggressive buyers stepping in
so what do you think the Market's going
to do you think the market is going to
go lower or go higher well when you
start seeing a lot of aggressive buying
in that's bullish for the market it's
really simple right it's it's
not you're not trying to build some
spaceship here right this Japanese Yen
this morning okay again we hit the high
and we sold off you know people say well
yeah you know you hit the high you got a
red candle you got sell well why didn't
the bars why didn't the market sell off
from point A why point B and not point a
well if you look at an orderflow
chart this is point a here but point B
you got 1 two three selling imbalances a
couple bars later you got a bar with
four selling imbalances right so you
know that's how you can tell when things
have shifted in the market you know you
can see on the way up you're seeing
buying imbalances coming in one two
three here one here you're going up you
make the new high you got some buying
and balances but now selling and
balances coming in you say you're not
convinced at this high of the day that
uh you know what we got it's kind of
mixed here because you got three buying
three selling imbalances in this bar but
you got a buying and balance previous
bar had a buying balance the other bar
had two buying and balances and you had
um you know a couple buying and balances
but by the time you get to the second
bar whack right the aggressive sellers
just hit all the bids here you know it's
36 against four 79 against four 37
against four 25 against
six and again you know this is the chart
you can see the nice move from you know
the the 9697 area on down to um you know
the
96 87
area but I'll be honest you know when
the Market's moving quickly you're
trying to digest everything that's
happening it's going to get very
confusing that's why I say let software
help you let your trading software show
you when aggressive buyers are stepping
in at lows or aggressive sellers are
coming out at highs you your trading
software should be able to show you
where multiple imbalances are and a lot
don't you know that that's why I ended
up creating my own software is because
you know as a Trader you know I would
look for this but I was really limited
to
just you know two markets Max maybe
because you there's a lot of stuff going
on and you're trying to process this in
real time this um you know especially
now the way these markets move you know
you're getting 20 point moves in you
know on a one minute bar in the um
NASDAQ you know that that's overwhelming
especially if you're trying to watch
NASDAQ trying to watch E minis mini da
throwing in crude and you know maybe one
or two other markets it's going to be
very difficult and if you're looking at
a normal Candlestick chart you're not
going to be able to see where these
imbalances are and you're going to miss
these great trading
opportunities right this is that low
there or that swing low here in this box
right here right you're coming down and
you see these bars with multiple buying
and balances now after it happens at the
end of the day you look back in your
chart you can say oh yeah look at all
these buy and balances as I should have
bought there but when you're trading
it's very easy to overlook it especially
if you're on a position in in one market
you your focus may be 95% on that one
market and you're going to be missing
these other opportunities right that's
why let the software highlight to you
bars with multiple imbalances right that
way you can see it right that the Mind
processes images 10,000 times faster
than it processes numbers or words right
so
what I had my software do you I've got a
lot of tools for Traders programmed into
my order flish Trader software one of
them is this multiple imbalances tool to
highlight basically put a a box
around the bar telling me hey you know
what this bar pay attention idiot you
know this Bar's got imbalances multiple
imbalances just as this bar this blue
green bar this other green bar has got a
lot of multiple um imbalances and when I
started to see them Bunch together then
I know right that aggressive buying is
coming into the market right you know on
a move down like you have here I'm not
surprised to see multiple selling
imbalances you the Market's moving down
you know people are are piling into the
market but when you hit a swing low or
the low of the day and all of a sudden
you see multiple buying and balances
coming in you know over a series of bars
that's a sign that's a sign that you
know what aggressive Traders are coming
into the market this is a very good
low-risk trading opportunity
because you can join in the bigger
Traders right the bigger Traders are the
ones that are going to move the market
and when they're aggressive that's who
you want to be trading alongside so when
you're trading live and the Market's
moving it's easy to overlook one little
piece of information such as bars with
multiple
imbalances that's why I created the
orderflows trader software my software
software I use in my trading to show me
situations like multiple imbalances that
way it's easier to follow multiple
markets right this is that move in the
e- minis right if you know I might have
very easily you can very easily Miss A
Move like this right off the low swing
low you know for a nice you know
10-point move up so when you're trading
on the side of aggressive Traders right
you're trading in sync with the market
that's what you want to do markets move
up because of aggressive buying
markets move lower because of aggressive
selling don't try to beat the aggressive
Traders join them don't be the fish
swimming up stream that that you know
you're trying to jump you know Bears
know you know the the they know that
when it's when these fish start swimming
Upstream all they got to do is just sit
there with their mouth open right and
then catch them don't be that fish
trying to swim upstream you know be the
guy on the bull that's to care about um
you know that that's joining in you know
the bull is going to move he's going to
run in Direction you just sit on them
and and enjoy the ride again you know
this is the Japanese Yen yesterday
right how can you determine aggressive
trading on a Candlestick chart well
answer you you can't you can't without
looking at the order flow right you're
seeing it right there it's clear as day
you know but if you have you know maybe
you can catch it on on a chart like this
maybe you can see it you know maybe you
trained yourself to see it but it's just
better to have a software that says hey
you know what you've got multiple whole
imbalances appearing right here at the
high of the day you know then you look
and then you put two and two together
and oh you know what I'm at the high of
the day I got multiple selling
imbalances you know this is probably a
high that's going to hold for now you
know and you take the short crude oil
yesterday right you're coming down big
40 Cent move down then you see you know
again if if you
are have trained yourself to look at it
look for it maybe you could pick it up
and real time when you're looking at
four or five other markets you know and
and doing your other things answering
emails or whatever when you're trading
um Maybe not maybe you can maybe you
can't but if you have the software that
says hey you know what you got multiple
imbalances appearing here you know at
this after this 40 Cent move down you
got all of a sudden you got multiple buy
and balances hey you know what that's
probably a trade you might want to take
now give you a word of caution okay
don't r run out and trade every bar with
multiple imbalances you got to put
everything you see in the market in
context you know a lot of people will
listen to a presentation like this up
till now and say oh you know all I got
to do is look for multiple imbalances
well you know part of trading trading
the way I I view it is is a puzzle okay
and you're always trying to put the
pieces of the puzzle together okay and
that's where Market context comes in you
know just as if you're doing a a regular
puzzle right with the pieces you can't
put a a piece for the side in the middle
or a piece from The Middle on the side
right that's what's called Market
context so for example um this is U mnq
right micro NASDAQ
and Market context is you know where do
you want to be buying where do you want
to be selling well you know on a move
down do you want to be selling at Point
a or point B you just had a move down
actually the point a should be a little
bit higher here um but you don't want to
be selling after a big move down what
you want to be doing is looking for a
point like C right after a move down you
want to be looking for the aggressive
buying just as after a move up you don't
necessarily want to be buying at Point D
you know me you could always add on you
know at various levels on the move up if
you got bars with multiple imbalances
there nothing wrong with that I do that
but the better entry is going to be at
the swing low rather than after a move
up and you know what the market gives
you many opportunities you if you miss a
trade Don't Panic don't say oh you know
I I miss getting short at a I going to
get short at B well no you know just
wait for a better opportunity and sure
enough it came two bars later at Point C
this time a long trade right you miss C
don't necessarily think you got to get
long at D you just wait for you know
when when the market makes a a new high
a swing High to get short and with
multiple
imbalances this was yesterday in the
cash open in the e- minis this yellow
area on the left is the cash open okay
Market just went sideways then what do
you see all of a sudden you're starting
to see the aggressive selling com into
the market you got to Bor with three
imbalances here another Bor with two
imbalances another Bor with another two
and then as you start breaking down more
selling imbalances so your first sign
that maybe this move is going to be
going lower was this first bar you know
at e33 that had multiple Sal imbalances
but you're still going sideways then
finally when it sort of breaks out of
this low area of the first 5 minutes
boom as you're breaking out multiple
selling imbalances and the market
proceeded to go down into the um you
know down to what 82 or so this bonds
yesterday right this is a four range
chart point a is the first low of the
day point but if you you just because
you hit the low of the day and you got a
green bar doesn't automatically mean the
Market's going to reverse and start
trading higher for a market to start
moving higher you need aggressive buyers
to come in you know not just one bar
where you know it closed higher than
where it
opened then you know Bar B the bar that
precedes Bar B this one right here at
803 it's actually when the low was made
but the next bar after the low is is
screaming at you saying hey aggressive
buyers are coming into this market right
what do you want to do right do you
think this Market's going to go down
well you know there's a chance there's
always a chance of anything happening in
the market but the the way to position
yourself is for a move up all right and
you started moving up and you see you
even hit this red bar where you've got
two buying imbalances okay market closed
down okay what do you make of that all
right well you got some aggressive
buying we got to watch to see what's
going to happen one that could be Supply
people offering it out but the
aggressive buying is quite strong you
got to watch what happens in the next
bar more aggressive buying coming in 27
against 586 obviously we took out this
high of this red bar with buying
imbalance another buying in balance and
again it it just moves
higher this is wheat
yesterday um you know so I I've showed
you crude oil I've showed you Japanese
Yen I've showed you mini micro NASDAQ
I've showed you e minis you know wheat
because and this is just yesterday right
so it
while pattern
and Order flow repeats in the market
they don't repeat identically you know
every Market is is slightly unique but
once you understand orderflow you could
apply it to any Market this is wheat
there a nice 5cent move right up off the
low you know you made three lows here A
B and
C right A B and C well if you bought a
you get stopped out again I'm not trying
to pick the lows right I'm always
looking for a reason to buy a low right
I'm not trying to predict the low oh hit
a low maybe I should start buying it we
had a green bar
no barb level B yeah it went up just
went sideways and hit the new low at C
but at C in this area of this low this
is where the aggressive Traders finally
came in caused the market imbalance to
occur and the market started
rallying right you could see this is the
low of the day right here in this green
bar but in this bar right here at
1044 you got three buying and balances
two bars uh three bars later four bars
later you got another three buying and
balances coming in you know even in this
other bar you it's kind of mixed two
selling two buying this one's got a
buying imbalance but you're not
seeing a lot of selling imbalances
coming and sure there's selling there's
always buying and selling going on in
the market but what you're looking for
is when aggressive buyers are in such
Force so to speak that it's causing the
market to go out of balance
that the market is is going to start
moving right directionally right
so hopefully by now you can see how
simple it
is to reduce when you reduce the market
to the basics right you're not trying to
oh you know we just had this move down I
got a green bar I got a buy oh you know
shcks I got stopped out there's a couple
more green bars maybe this is the low
you know or you know hey we finally hit
a low finally know once twice oh third
time's got to be the charm I got to buy
it let the market tell
you aggressive buyers are coming into
the market or aggressive sellers are
present in the market right the market
gives you a lot of information it's
whether you want to use it or not if
you're just looking at a normal chart
normal Candlestick or bar chart it's
just giving you the Open high low close
and again you know some people will say
why I don't need orderflow because yeah
it's you know any fool can see that you
got a big red bar down sellers are in
control yeah but you don't see the big
red bar down until after the bar is
closed okay it starts out as a small red
bar gets a little bigger gets a little
bigger then oh my gosh yeah this big red
bar sellers must be in control well okay
it goes down sellers are in control but
it hits the low at some point the
Market's going to bottom out and what
order flow is going to help
is it's going to tell you that the
aggressive buyers are in control right
just as you know here in the bonds yeah
we've been trading down down down we hit
a low bounced up hit another low but now
the aggressive buyers came in right in
quite strong um you know 19
1,917
653 158 is not that strong but you know
the 1900 right off the low is is pretty
strong you know it's telling me that you
know there was a lot of sellers here and
the buyers ate through it you know there
was almost 2,000 contracts on the offer
here at ' 08 but buyers were you know
damn the torpedos you know this is a
great buying opportunity you know I'll
buy everything you have you know offer
me more at this price because at this
price I know it's a great deal I think
the Market's going to go higher and sure
enough the market went higher you know
just like again if a market is going
sideways markets make moves they go up
down they go sideway ways right so you
know after a move up often times the
market goes sideways after a move down
Market often goes
sideways excuse
me you know at Cash open you know
important times of the day you know Cash
open is an important time of the day for
trading equities you know Market's
trying to find its footing you know is
you which way is the order book leaning
towards at this time you know is it
buying or is it
selling and you can see early on it was
telling you you know what it's kind of
going sideways but it's slanted more
towards selling okay great you know what
I could take a nice lowrisk trade you if
I'm getting short here at 87 88 where's
my risk it's just back into 90 you know
you're risking a couple points to
capture you know maybe you know at least
one to one hopefully two to one maybe
three to one here right it's it's like I
said it's the Market's speaking to you
the Market's telling you what to do you
know it's like hey there's all this
aggressive trading going on all either
aggressive buying or aggressive selling
do something about it okay
so like I said
when you talking about Market context
when you're at highs of days or swing
highs look for aggressive sellers when
you're at the low of the day or swing
lows look for aggressive buyers look for
that potential reversal in the market
right but you got to look for that at
certain points in the market so this
past 40 minutes or so hopefully you'll
agree it's been time well spent you know
honestly I can't cover everything in in
a 40 minute or 60-minute training
session but hopefully by now you should
you should understand the importance of
aggressive buyers and the importance of
imbalances in the market so I've got a
special offer so you can get everything
you need to know about orderflow and if
you act fast I'll give you a very
special deal you know the charts I
showed you are generated from my
orderflows Trader software which runs on
ninja Trader 8 you know I'm a Futures
Trader I've always been a futures Trader
um ninja Trader 8 works fine for for
Futures Trading I've used it for gosh
how many years now eight years more or
less
and it works it's stable right I don't
really have any issues you
know recently you know a lot of these
trading platforms as the Market's been
making new highs they've been locking
out people you know people can't access
their account honestly I've never had
that problem um with Ninja Trader I
think in the past eight years I've had
one problem where something happened in
the euro currency Market moved fast my
old computer I was trading on locked up
okay that was it you honestly in eight
years to have one major issue is is is
nothing so you know people ask you know
does it work on trade station or to
trade of8 no it doesn't right now it
works on ninja Trader 8 and what it is
is the volume footprint chart that you
see in this presentation with I I showed
you multiple imbalances in the bar right
putting the Box around it something
simple there's 17 total orderflow
related tools in the orderflows trader
okay rather than just having the normal
footprint you know the tools are like
going to tell you when there's a
potential sweep in the market when
there's Market weakness and you know
obviously imbalances and there's
different types of imbalances value um
areas it just really gives you a lot of
information um from the market it's
really easy to set up it takes two
minutes if you're familiar with Ninja
Trader you're familiar with how easy it
is to set up um an indicator um order
flows Trader is an add-on you don't even
need any templates because the once you
load it and install it that's the
settings the default is literally the
charts that I have up on the screen here
and normally I sell it for $88.99 and
really what it is the orderflow trader
is takes my knowledge of orderflow
trading and puts it into a program um so
you can see what you know the big
Traders are doing in the market but
having software is one thing right you
got to know how to use it so I'm going
to give you my orderflows trading course
for free I sell for 297 every day on my
website but I also give you Advanced
Training with the orderflows Inner
Circle video series it's not available
to the trading public right to get it it
cost $500 it's 56 videos on Advanced
orderflows tricks tips and Analysis so
when you add the software the training
and the Inner Circle video series that's
already almost
$1,700 but I realize it's one thing to
learn from videos and books you know but
that takes that's hard for a lot of
people it takes discipline and
commitment but what I found is it's much
easier for people to learn in a live
classroom session so for the past two
years I've already got over there's
already every week on Tuesday nights I
do a live training session where you can
come in ask questions um you know I talk
about what's happening in the market you
know whether you got question about the
software about the market about a tool
that's where you can ask and interact
with me you know every week ready
there's already 102 sessions if you
can't attend you get the recordings this
is the recording area you know some
people charge up to $200 a month for for
training for what you know you're buying
the software you should get it for
free but for just a one-time payment of
$749 go to orderflows docomo three and
that will take you to the page where you
can um you know proceed with getting
started with orderflows but a special
bonus for investor inspiration I've got
a an extra bonus The orderflow Playbook
normally I sell for $297 you're going to
get it for free so go to orderflows
decom page looks like this scroll down
get here click on buy now click that
button to get started takes you to
PayPal I don't get your information
PayPal processes everything and it's
just a one-time payment of $749 so
you're going to get the orderflows
trader software the trading course the
inter circle video series access to the
weekly live Group Training The
orderflows Playbook now if you stuck
around want a copy of my book go to
orderflows
docomo and it'll take you to this page
you got to enter your name and email and
after you hit submit it'll take you to
the download page so you can download
that book so getting started is easy you
know you just got to get up off your
butt type in this URL
www.fls.ga.gov orig version was
orderflows then there was order flows 2
now we're on order flows 3 it's free
right the only payments you need to do
is is to ninja Trader for their platform
but it'll work on the free platform and
your data fees and that's it so thanks
you know just get started thanks for
attending today's presentation Anna I
think I'm exhausted my time everyone
I've put the information the links in
the chat for downloading the book as
well as getting started with uh
orderflows
um software so thanks Anna I'll throw it
back to you